avec 350 millions de joueurs à travers
le monde fortnight est le jeu le plus
populaire le jeu vidéo le plus populaire
de tous les temps
une vitrine hors norme qu'on choisi de
s'offrir les châteaux de la loire pour
quelques dizaines de milliers d'euros
cinq monuments ont été modélisées pour
faire partie du décor proposé aux gamers
avec l'idée bien sûr de faire de ces
ados de futurs visiteurs de chambord
encore du clos lucé paul boyer voici le
château de chambord version virtuelle
jardin façade intérieure ont été
reproduits à l'identique pour le jeu
vidéo fortnight à l'initiative du projet
la région centre val de loire et l'
agence tourangelle wsc c'est un public
qui n'ont pas l'habitude de toucher à
savoir les 15 25 ans qui sont pas
forcément les plus présents
dans leurs lieux et dans leur domaine et
leur château respectifs donc c'est super
c'est super intéressant de pouvoir les
accrocher avec le biais du jeu vidéo
le principe de force n'a été simple se
battre contre les autres joueurs pour
être le dernier survivant
une recette couronnée de succès dans
d'autres jeux pour ce spécialiste ces
lieux ont toute leur place dans
fortnight dire qu'il prend des faits on
va dire de l'histoire des faits réels
qu'il détourne un petit peu pour le
rendre vidéoludique parce que bon bah
l'histoire vraiment pur des fois peut
être un petit peu rébarbatif ça reste
une vie tous les jours mais il ya des
centaines ou des milliers d'années l'un
des objectifs est bien sûr d'inciter les
joueurs à venir voir ces lieux avec plus
de 350 millions de joueurs inscrits dans
le monde
les châteaux compte bien faire carton
plein et c'est qu'effectivement une fois
que les joueurs auront joué sur la carte
représentant chambord que ce soit
d'ailleurs des français ou des étrangers
bah ça leur donne envie s'y sont jamais
venus à chambord en devenir tout
simplement effectivement cette fois-ci
visité en vrai la télévision solari
diffusera à partir du 4 décembre sur la
plateforme twitch tv5 émission en prime
time
ensuite des joueurs du monde entier
pourront se connecter afin de s'amuser
dans ces lieux chargés d'histoire
belle façon de marier ea sports et
patrimoine